what are we going to cover in this
program so in this program we're going
to cover data wrangling machine learning
and statistics for high throughput data
unsupervised and supervised types of
analysis machine learning and data
visualization
unsupervised and supervised learning
feature selection and signature patterns
as well as regression and generalized
linear models and then deep learning for
different types of deemed learning
models and their applications now in
this course specifically we're going to
focus on python we're not going to learn
multiple languages at the same time but
all of the same information is on the
omics logic portal also in R so if you
are more familiar with r you want to
know how to use these methods in R we
can switch between those
uh because I think ultimately they're
pretty similar
now let's briefly talk about the process
of uh kind of figuring out what python
is all about
so uh you will be given
exercises during this whole course where
you will kind of learn uh syntax of
coding and syntax of coding in this
beginning stage means that let's take a
piece of code and kind of understand
what it says maybe by changing it here
and there substituting different
terminology but learning how to deal
with this kind of data so on Monday we
went through a few examples of kind of
walking through those exercises and
starting to use different pieces of code
that were provided and explained to load
and display data ultimately a similar
approach will be used for more and more
complex analysis so you will kind of be
given a problem learn the code
learn how to modify the code to modify
outputs maybe go into specific settings
and modify them then apply something to
data and that's how you know you have
completed now this approach is
consistent across Python and R but we
will focus on python in this class